the intention is to be able to One Stop
Shop your entire online life some people
are way too smart for my simple monkey
brain see when you explain it like that
way cooler yeah but when you explain
like that it sounds like one thing but I
couldn't even find the [__] app on my
phone for like 10 minutes yesterday
[Music]
Twitter is now X
what do you mean yeah what does it mean
dude wait what what does it mean yeah
the app changed like if you see if you
have Twitter yeah it's not Twitter
anymore it's just the X it's just the X
yeah what I read was
um elon's been owning x.com so he just
wanted a reason to use it oh is that
what it is I don't know that's what I
read somewhere but like you know it's
something more complex than that but I
like that but it's one of the most name
recognized Brands like on the earth
that's why he spent 65 billion dollars
for it why are you ditching it
immediately 44 billion 44 billion yeah I
wonder why does it explain why he
changed it to X yeah okay yeah yeah okay
so he originally uh got the URL for
x.com for like millions of dollars like
multiple years ago one he's also
infatuated with the character because
you know it's basically aspirin Asperger
guys
and model X right like Tesla yep and his
kid is named X so he loves he he loves
the shape nice yeah uh and the whole
point even from the beginning of
speculation was when he had x.com
because everyone's like what is this
what's this like [__] genius
billionaire gonna do with this like for
for years people are always speculating
and then you know information from like
trusted sources will eventually leak out
about the idea that it was supposed to
be a One-Stop shop for like all things
online
similar to an akin to WeChat in Chinese
everybody familiar with WeChat in China
yeah [__] everything on there it's a
communication chat platform social posts
purchasing like you you can there's
WeChat pay where literally every [__]
store in China basically you never have
to pull out your wallet you could just
use your phone you scan WeChat codes it
is super effective and efficient
um so everything works on there you can
basically do everything on WeChat
sending files blah blah blah right so
the intention was to always do that with
X or x.com and then he purchased Twitter
and then was uh basically had this whole
meeting with his board and stuff and
people to tell them that uh X is now
going to for sure be a thing and Twitter
was going to be an accelerator for it so
turning Twitter into X is part of the
process to create a One-Stop online
solution because he already has a user
way more sense dude he's gonna I think
this is a good move so it's one of the
many functions yeah right it's just
rebranding now because that's also kind
of like elon's ml 100 hyper for a long
time until delivery but that's also the
thing he was never about crazy marketing
just like Tesla right he doesn't Market
[__] he has this philosophy that it's a
brilliant and good product it will
Market itself anyway so right now it's
just a branding change uh but what who
knows when the rollout will actually be
for when because even now on what was
Twitter it's not just 140 character
tweets anymore you know you can do so
much [__] on there now that like hasn't
been done hours of video on there wow
Tucker Tucker Carlson after he left or
he got fired from Fox or whatever his
whole his whole show's on Twitter now or
it was X but yeah so the idea that you
could do that
um their intentions are to roll out
things like paid subscriptions and stuff
like that so like imagine patreon but
through X the whole thing is to be able
to have your entire Financial portfolio
and stuff like that in terms of payment
processing and like user interface and
posses for businesses and everything
like that so you can do that
um outside of just the things that you
quote unquote used to tweet under post
like imagine if you're regular social
posting uh or photo posting like
Instagram or whatever the heck also
happened there in the same place that
you do those stuff slash chat slash
email slash whatever like the intention
is to be able to One Stop Shop your
entire online life some people are way
too smart for my simple monkey brain see
when you explain it like that way cooler
yeah well when you explain like that it
sounds like one thing but I couldn't
even find the [__] app on my phone
for like 10 minutes yesterday because I
changed the icon over so it's not blue
anymore it's just black X and I wasn't
even looking for that it should have
made it a blue background or something
I mean in a couple years we might be
like this is tight it almost seems like
he wants to just completely wipe the
memory of Twitter I think you you have
to right because it had such a bad rap
with him coming in and everybody was
like oh he's running Twitter you're
firing everybody I think it's probably
smart that he started it's like he's
really just erasing it and taking all of
the assets now it feels like elon's you
know that's true why didn't he just make
his own then oh [__] because no one
would have they wouldn't have talked
about as much as this because he's
buying the user base isn't it he's
buying a user base okay that's huge that
makes sense you know but the crazy thing
is now people apparently are also
auctioning on eBay old iPhones that have
the old Twitter logo that haven't been
updated yet for like over ten thousand
dollars who's buying that the [__] is
buying nobody hopefully but probably a
lot of people but probably some people
like I hope they make their money right
because they can't update the old ones
they're Flappy birding basically yeah
they just want the old logo and
something because now it's a a [__]
phenomenal cultural Relic it's a
collectible yeah it's like the
PlayStation game that horror game
it's like Silent Hill or some [__] oh
yeah it was like a demo and you can buy
old PlayStations that have that demonic
because PlayStation got rid of it after
a while do you remember that yeah yeah
it was like but like you could you have
to spend like thousands of dollars for a
[__] PlayStation because this is old
demo and then as soon as you buy it and
play it you're like that wasn't worth it
that's ultimate buyers or more exactly
that's ten thousand dollars you're like
oh [__] it is a demo
what do you guys think about a One-Stop
shop online I think that's great I think
so many people have tried it like
everywhere tries it right I don't know
it's different to execute it we'll see I
think what's the closest thing we have
here in the states for a One-Stop shop
is it Facebook maybe Facebook Apple
because you got Apple pay you have
[__] iOS what about chatting I guess
iMessage yeah yeah I mean that's that
one is kind of a One-Stop shop Without
Really realizing it which is interesting
do you think the timing of this and
threads is kind of like coincidental or
you think the whole threads was a
complete [__] ripoff they even used
old Twitter engineering yeah but that's
what Mark Zuckerberg always does yeah
that's what's called zucking he
literally is like see something it's
like all right let's put that on
Facebook yeah because he took Snapchat
but threads is in the clubhouse grave
now oh is it already yeah oh dude I
didn't think it was gonna I was gonna go
in I saw everybody posting about that it
blipped and then the user base cringe
yeah big ass Spike and then just said
what drastic abandonment because this is
exactly what Twitter is so if you
already have Twitter and there's already
a community and like yeah your routine
also it's like why would you go on two
twitters I don't know and the news of X
kind of dwarfed the existence of threats
so maybe that's also another randomly
brilliant thing yeah that is he timed it
well or maybe he knew that threads was
coming out so he's like all right let me
just wait maybe he's even like X ain't
ready but because you made threads [__]
it I could do this yeah let's just do it
Bill Gates zucked um Steve Jobs pretty
hard when when uh if you remember when
Windows came out they they copied Apple
OS like big time yeah oh really oh yeah
but he's also saved him two he saved
them later yeah later later yeah yeah
when he because after Steve Jobs got
kicked out and then Apple was like hey
uh Steve you want to come back cause uh
we're gonna lose money in two months
completely I'll just take the company
and then he's like well [__] what am I
gonna do and he's like Bill I'm in
trouble and then Bill's like I'll give
you all the money you need I'm just your
partner now yep so I mean it's it's
almost later yeah that was later though
but in the beginning yeah you he did
steal he stole and but Bill Gates stole
everything stole everything that was one
of his biggest things like in Silicon
Valley he would he's not inventor just
give people whatever some company was
working on for free like like the
Microsoft Words and the excels and all
that kind of [__] like he would just
take your idea that you were trying to
like see around uh raise money with and
then sell and he just copies it and it's
free now on Windows and then you're
[__] he's like she in
you know what's crazy it almost feels
like at least to me that like the
incorporation of X becoming a One-Stop
shop is not necessarily
of imitation of WeChat as it is a war
against WeChat it feels like he knows
that WeChat could take over American
audiences because that's already an
established model and China in a way is
taking over American audiences with Tick
Tock so he's trying to be the WeChat
before WeChat is the WeChat and that's
kind of what elon's about like trying to
be pro-free speech and all that yeah
exactly and of course this of course
he's going to see the future in a way
that normal people like us which if
people were perceptive enough to like
even see that perspective should rally
behind the idea and everybody really
underestimates how much they forget that
they hated a change
yeah everyone always hates the change
and then they love it and they forgot
that they're one of the haters in the
beginning look how many times Instagram
has changed and everyone hated it every
time and then we just even when the icon
changes remember like when the icon of
Instagram changed from the camera to
like just the what it is now what is it
plus it's generational again there's
people that are entering X not knowing
Twitter and they just accept that that's
what it is and everyone who complained
kind of doesn't use it anymore even if
just by looking at it I kind of like it
already I don't I don't care honestly
it's just it was just a pain in the ass
finding the the icon yeah because I was
like you know though when Elon took it
over Twitter became very enjoyable I
agree I agree yeah because
well during the whole like like you know
lockdown and wokeness and all that stuff
Twitter and all the social media was
getting
um
very encouraged by the CIA and FBI to
quiet down like certain things and then
like I don't know I like to see the
discourse happening right or like it was
so preachy from one angle yeah and it
was like it was just the woke leftist
stuff right and I was like oh I don't I
don't know I only went on Twitter to
like see free porn but now I'm like now
it's really not fun
and then when he came on it's like
having a troll CEO makes trolling really
fun and then there's all these troll
accounts that like are parity accounts
and then they pretend to be certain like
fake conservative fake liberal and I
love that dude it got way less serious
now it's yeah now it's so funny yeah
right yeah yeah for for X it's
interesting too because as much as some
people say like you'll hear it all the
time people go nobody [__] Twitter
but that's honestly a lie dude because
if you're running into tweets on
Instagram you're not running into
Instagrams on Twitter No it's like
screen caps of tweets yeah you're still
seeing tweets and [__] off the platform
and I think that's a big deal the same
way we would see tick tocks on Instagram
is the same thing it's like people are
using it maybe you don't if you're
saying like no one uses it but like
someone's using it I'm not sports fans
use it a lot I know yeah a lot of sports
fans crypto space uses it a lot
um stocks they use it a lot and on top
of that uh I mean people that love only
fans also soon X is gonna have an
exchange on there too where you're going
to be able to swap kryptos swap stop wow
see that's the next level bro that's so
crazy that's incredible that's smart
because everybody wants their [__] on
one spot anyway so you know how like
during uh
pre-pre-elon there would be like fact
checking right so like people would post
[__] and fact checking will come out
when he got on they started fact
checking the White House that's the best
so in the White House was supposed that
was that was some tough [__] I was like
oh my God
they're all medicine I'll never forget
when Biden got elected and that that
July 4th he's like he they tweeted
something from the White House account
that was like you know I think July 4th
is going to be cheaper than in last year
by 18 cents or some [__] and like I
remember just back then seeing like is
does everyone see that this is complete
[__] or what and then yeah when
Community notes came out they did a
similar tweet like about around some
kind of holiday and it immediately got
community noted yeah and I love that
[__] right and it said like oh some
facts are not in line with whatever the
five yeah with the rate of inflation
it's great to see that and they do that
on on X now yeah oh that's it's called a
community note where they do like a yeah
they did it during Twitter so they would
be talking about like how hey like jobs
are back inflation is down all this and
then they got community noted like nah
like everything's expensive what are you
talking about that's tight and it's like
it's not even about left or right people
are working more jobs yeah yeah jobs are
back but they're working more part-time
jobs and people have multiple jobs now
more than they did before and then they
also were like it doesn't count if
people come back from Lockdown to start
working because it's like it's not new
jobs created and they're also
uncomfortably hustling it's not like oh
I have a nice job and I'm chill it's
like no they're not having a good time
go talk to people they're serious
they're stressed I really like in this
climate of uh now that all this shit's
coming out with they're finding the
records of of uh Facebook
um Shadow Banning conservative pages and
[__] yeah like at least there's
something that's objectively calling out
[__] on both sides yep that's what
we all need right now I think we do
because it does happen on both sides
it's not it's not yeah it's not
one-sided you guys trying to line up it
doesn't happen perfectly on both sides
but it's happening at least it happens
to my account because if I see some woke
[__] I immediately block that person
[Laughter]
[Music]